Rafaela I know you feel grateful yes to
the wonderful company and they have done
things that no farmer will do there's a
park now there's no roads are better
there's some houses but the wages are
still minimum and the water is to a
problem we don't think that waterfall
here we didn't even like it for that
ditches so it's really big but what is
here is really a bit sometimes he comes
with our fennec yes so the farm workers
don't have water to drink but the trees
have plenty of water to draw I know for
the one yeah almost all the water in
this valley is full of toxicity one of
the first things that happened to me
when I started working here is I was
going door-to-door visiting residents
and a couple of women said come in and
come in and they offered me a glass of
what they were calling lost hills
lemonade and they were laughing about it
and I could smell it I could smell the
chlorine and that was our introduction
to the water here have you asked the
water district here why it's coming out
yellow I have in the response that I
received is well it's an infrastructure
problem because lots of pipes and a lot
of pipes in the house but with all this
infrastructure changes to the Resnick's
to improve the water system you know the
infrastructure of the pipes going into
people's homes you know and this is what
we're seeing throughout current county
that some areas are parched and some
farms are drying up because who holds
the right to that water and who is going
to benefit most from being able to grow
more pistachios and more pomegranates
that's the California story there has
always been a fight over the water and
just like any war
just collateral damage
[Music]
you